millionen deutsche sind nicht geimpft
die allermeisten von ihnen keine
querdenker keine impfgegner sie sind
einfach hin und hergerissen am zweifel
haben sorgen sind einfach bisher nicht
überzeugt von der impfung sowie er josua
kimmig bayern-star er will sich noch
nicht impfen lassen und jetzt jetzt regt
sich der eine teil deutschlands über ihn
auf findet kimmig heuchlerisch auch weil
er teil dieser kampagne war mit corona
hier käme ich zum beispiel aber im
krankenhaus besucht zusammen mit leon
goretzka dem ich über ihn diskutiert man
jetzt auch in der bundesregierung das
sagt zum beispiel regierungssprecher
steffen seibert jetzt im fall
ich habe zu diesem
zu diesen äußerungen von joshua kimmig
das gesagt was ich für die
bundesregierung zu sagen habe wir alle
oder viele von uns kennen sein corona
engagement schätzen ist auch insofern
hat er eine durchaus überraschende
aussage gemacht und ich habe hier nun
dargelegt dass es viele gute
informationen auch für jeden zugänglich
gibt die etwaige fragen etwaige zweifel
die ja jeder haben kann
beantworten und da ist sicherlich ein
fußball nationalspieler erst mal nicht
anders als jeder von uns weil es eine
sehr persönliche entscheidung ist sich
impfen zu lassen gleichwohl
gibt es antworten auf die fragen die er
ganz offensichtlich hat und
liegen erkenntnisse vor und die
häufig werden bei ihm noch einmal eine
gewisse wirkung entfalten zeigt ein
bisschen unverständnis der
regierungssprecher ein bisschen
hilflosigkeit aber auch und vor allen
dingen im netz gibt es reichlich
aufregung über kimmig das ist aber der
eine teil deutschlands der andere findet
das richtig gut dass kimmig sich jetzt
geoutet hat dass er ganz offen sagt
welche im zweifel eher hat so wie eben
noch hunderttausende andere deutsche und
wir bei bild wollen ihnen erst mal die
fakten hier auf den tisch legen und
ihnen zeigen wie überhaupt der aktuelle
stand beim impfen gerade ist also
aktuell sind
55,1 millionen deutsche vollständig
geimpft ungefähr 66 prozent also knapp
23 von uns allen und dann ist ja die
entscheidende frage wie viel so genannte
impft durchbrüche gibt es also wie viele
menschen erkranken an corona obwohl sie
geimpft sind aktuell davon knapp 100000
sagt das robert koch institut das sind
die zahlen die wir eben bekommen und auf
den intensivstationen waren zwölf
prozent aller menschen die dort zwischen
1859 jahre alt jahren gelandet sind die
wahren geimpft also ungefähr jeder achte
der auf der intensivstation liegt liegt
da aktuell auch obwohl er geimpft ist
und bei den über 60 jährigen sind die
zahlen dann ein bisschen höher
möglicherweise auch das thematisieren
wir gleich weil die impfung schon ein
bisschen länger zurückliegt fliegen wir
noch mal durch andere wichtige zahlen
rund um die korona impfung durch aktuell
sind ja
1686 corinna patienten auf den
intensivstationen wir haben noch
tausende betten frei also es wird wieder
etwas knapper die situation wird wieder
angespannter in den krankenhäusern aber
noch nicht besorgniserregend das ist
aktuell das was das robert koch institut
und vor allen dingen dass die wie das
zentralregister der
intensivmediziner dazu sagt außerdem
schauen wir drauf auf die infect
effektivität also wann lässt der schutz
der impfung möglicherweise nach man sagt
es schützt vor hospitalisierung also
dafür dass man im krankenhaus landet
ungefähr 90 prozent so hoch der schutz
bei allen unter 60 also man kann relativ
sicher sein dass man mit einer impfung
eben nicht im krankenhaus
landet vor intensivstation sogar mit 94
prozent und ford mit 98 prozent also
diese zahlen zeigen die wirksamkeit der
korona impfung und jetzt die empfehlung
der stiko der ständigen impfkommission
wann soll man eigentlich auffrischen
also wann sollte man sich so eine so
genannte booster impfung die tritt
impfung eigentlich holen und empfiehlt
die stiko das derzeit für menschen über
70 jahre für bewohner von pflegeheimen
für mitarbeiter in diesen einrichtungen
in pflegeheimen krankenhäusern also die
die an der korona front arbeiten und
dass wenn die zweite impfung geben sechs
monate oder länger zurückliegt dann die
stiko sagt dann bitte eine booster
impfung und wir wollen jetzt mit dem
hygiene professor klaus-dieter zastrow
über die großen sorgen sprechen die
viele menschen die ablagen allen voran
der chemisch schön dass sie hier bei uns
schon möglichen guten morgen für morgen
nehme ich hatte gesagt er setzt auf
einen tod impfstoffe möchte darauf
warten wie unterscheidet sich dieser
impfstoff denn von anderen impfstoffen
ja da bin ich etwas verblüfft denn es
ist ja ein tod im stoff die entweder
haben also zwischen lebens im stoff oder
abgeschwächten leben im stoffen und tote
im stoffen ist ja der unterschied dass
wir zb entweder lebende viren impfen sie
sind also im impfstoff drin oder
abgeschwächte lebende erreger die durch
eine entsprechende behandlung nicht
wirklich einen vollends krankheitsbild
ausbilden können das war früher bei den
pocken so das haben wir bei der
tuberkulose so gehabt das war noch die
meisten im schadensfälle aber hier
handelt sich um einen tod im stop
feeling gar keine lebenden viren drin
und auch nicht abgeschwächt lebende also
da liegt er leider oder glücklicherweise
völlig daneben und
an sich haben die bayern ja eine
hervorragende medizinische abteilung ich
denke da gibt es auch wie man der das
weiß das macht das ja nicht leicht hat
er wird genau das er gemacht haben der
wird mit seinen ärzten der vermutlich
täglich darüber gesprochen haben der hat
viel gelesen das zeigt ja auch dass er
sich mit dem thema auseinander gesetzt
hat dass er eben nicht einfach pauschal
sagt ich bin total gegen die impfung
sondern dass er das für sich reflektiert
hat und das sag ich hab da einfach
zweifel ich bin skeptisch und jetzt die
schwierige aufgabe und offenbar der
region sprecher weiss auch nicht mehr
richtig weiter die regierung weiß auch
nicht mehr richtig weiter wie kriegt man
ihnen jetzt an die impf nadeln sie
werden solche fälle auch canon von
leuten die keine corona leugner keine
totalen impfgegner sind und die trotzdem
diese zweifel in sich tragen also wenn
es mit diesen fakten die wir jetzt auf
den tisch gelegt haben auch noch nicht
lang wie wie macht man es jetzt wie
kriegt man den kimmig an die im nadel
naja also man müsste ihnen sicherlich
nochmal genauer aufklären und sich mit
ihm unterhalten zum beispiel was ist
jetzt tot im schiff und was lebte der
die sorge ist ja durchaus berechtigt
aber eigentlich jetzt zu diesem
zeitpunkt lange nicht mehr wenn wir
wissen es ist kein leben dämmstoffe es
ist also folgen diesem stoff geht keine
gefahr aus mit bei dem neben dem stoff
oder abgeschwächte neben stimmt wie
immer im hintergrund vielleicht erkranke
ich jetzt auch also das kann hier aber
überhaupt gar nicht passiert das müssten
die noch mal wirklich gut besprechen mit
ihnen das damit er das auch verstehen
aus der ecke machen sie es doch selbst
bieten gespräch an für user ja mach ich
mache ich gehe ja und wenn dazu schaut
dann hat das schon ja aber die
die sicherheit die wir an der stelle
haben die haben wir die sie sagten eben
gerade ob ich auch leute kenne die sich
nicht impfen lassen wollen also die
meisten die die in sagen immer ja ich
will noch mal abwarten und die sagen mir
auch ich bin gegen alles andere wie
immer aber das ist ja ein ganz neuer
impfstoff gibt es ja noch nicht mal ein
dreivierteljahr
dagegen kann man tatsächlich wenig sagen
man kann eigentlich nur sagen er ist
zugelassen jetzt haben wir sagen auch da
hat es ja schon
arzneimittel probleme mal irgendwo
gegeben das heißt bei der zulassung auch
ich ja auch schief gegangen ist
und
aber man muss eben immer sehen und das
war ja wenn sie an die zeit denken bevor
wir den impfstoff hatten ja da letzte
jeder nach dem impfstoff und auf der
anderen seite standen die bilder von
bergamo er also jeder hat gesagt er mit
dem impfstoff egal wie egal ob das
sputnik oder sonstwie ist und ich will
einfach nicht auf der intensivstation
gelangen und diese einstellung ist
eigentlich auch richtig dass denn man
weiß nie wie
stark der verlauf ist bei solak ohne
erkrankung und wir haben auch wir haben
auch bisher auch immer gesagt die jungen
leute erwischt es dann auch vielleicht
noch ein bisschen stärker als es ging
immer hin und her
stark schützt mich die impfung noch man
hat immer gedacht ach dann kriegt den
pieks und eines das thema jetzt zum vom
tisch und jetzt sehen wir es gibt eben
jetzt auch viele zunehmend erkrankte die
trotzdem geimpften hinterher kann glaube
ich auch viel verunsicherung bei den
menschen die sich fragen wenn ich bin
geimpft also damit müsste ich doch jetzt
auf der sicheren seite sein das heißt
wer braucht den dritten pigs wie sicher
bin ich überhaupt mit dem fall also
sinnvoll wäre jetzt natürlich also
erstmal noch mal 55 millionen leute
hatten wir schon vorher gezeigt und
jetzt haben 100.000 durchbrüche
also die muss man jetzt mal genau
untersuchen was ist denn da los also im
durchbrüche bzw wir nennen als auch im
versager ja das ist sie mutter ist denkt
man kann nichts dazu und nahrung gerecht
naja aber
die bilden eben keine antikörper test
gibt es bei allen impfungen und
und zwar nicht so häufig aber auch hier
hunderttausend klingt natürlich fiel
aber in der korrelation zum 55 millionen
ist eben nicht viel gehen sie bei
solchen fällen auch davon aus dass
möglicherweise bei der impfung was
schief lief aber wir haben jetzt
millionen deutschland einfach geimpft
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass da mal zu
wenig impfstoff in der spritze war oder
vielleicht doch nur wie eine salzige
flüssigkeit wie wir es ja auch mal
einzelnen fällen gehört haben oder das
ist einfach nicht richtig rein gespritzt
wurde ja also das war immer mein erster
gedanke als ich davon hörte dass er
diese erkrankungen trotz der impfungen
und
das zählt auch dazu also im bereich
ist diesmal der lehre über die impfung
wird auch immer gesagt wenn du
impfschäden hast beziehungsweise
komplikationen erst mal überprüfen sind
die normalen bedingungen eingehalten
werden so wurden bei diesen impfstoff
dieses jahr am anfang und das ist auch
ein bisschen entschärft worden die
kühlkette muss stimmen da war von minus
40 grad am mainzer nur noch 20 unserer
aber
auch sowas muss man achten dann sage ich
mal wir haben ja dann deutschlandweit
diese impfzentren aus dem boden
gestampft und
ich kann mich auch erinnern dass man
händeringend leute gesucht haben die das
machen da will ich niemandem zu nahe
treten ob das immer so wirklich lege
artis das was geführt war ein
öffentlicher helfer es ist ja klar dass
die nicht alle komplett angelernt waren
genau das heißt auch da könnte einiges
schiefgelaufen sein auch da ist könnte
diese etwas zunehmende zahl der
durchbrüche teilweise zumindest
untergang und das muss man aufarbeiten
dann musste damals habe ich es wirklich
mal gucken das ja kein problem nach zu
gucken ob da wirklich immer alles
gestellt wäre ja sehr hilfreich wenn man
weiß das sind ganz andere fehler gewesen
da wären wir glücklich